can you pull up the mark uh the john
hopkins article i just want to read this
and get get uh jordan's that article
yeah so so here's cnn msnbc new york
times wapo washington post completely
avoid john hopkins study finding uh
coveted lockdowns ineffective fyi would
you say john hopkins is a conservative
organization like hoover institute no or
heritage johns hopkins is one of the
most reliable medical
scientific research enterprises
universities in the world bar none
that's very important for yeah
it's extremely reliable so it's not like
it's a cnn no no this is like this is
harvard oxford cambridge level johns
hopkins especially in the medical domain
so watches abc cbs nbc also ignored the
anti-lockdown study so go up let me read
this so here we go there has been a
full-on media blockout in the study
online the ineffectiveness of lockdowns
to prevent coveted debts according to
john hopkins university manage analysis
of several studies lockdowns during
first coveted wave in spring of 2020
only reduced coverage mortality by 0.2
that is not a lot in us and in europe
while the meta-analysis concludes that
lockdowns have had little to no public
health effect they have imposed enormous
economic and social costs
where they have been adopted the
researcher wrote in consequence
lockdown's policies are ill-founded and
should be rejected as a pandemic policy
instrument if you can go a little higher
i want to read the next two and i'll get
jordan thoughts however the johns
hopkins study received no mention on any
of the five liberal networks this week
according to
uh grabian transcripts cnn msnbc abc cbs
nbc all ignored anti-lockdown's findings
after having spent much of the pandemic
shaming red states with minimal
restrictions and events deemed by
critics as super spreaders it wasn't
just the networks avoiding the study the
new york times the washington post the
associated press reuters usa today axios
politico amongst other outlets also
tuned a black a blind eye to the
findings according to search results
jordan how important is this research
like how important is is this analysis
that we're reading here right now what
does this tell us i should tell you what
a meta-analysis is please begin with
well
imagine there's a group of studies done
on a particular topic and you write a
review and you try to interpret the
findings uh that
was called a narrative review you use
your opinion in some sense to
wade through the data and try to
understand what the compilation of
studies reveals well there were
techniques developed 25 years ago that
are statistical where you can
aggregate the statistical results from
studies statistically so you do a
statistical analysis of all the
statistical analysis and that's a
meta-analysis and hypothetically it's
more objective and there's some truth to
that claim you still have to select
which studies to include but i i don't
believe that that was a detriment in
this particular case and so
solid methodology
and it's basically something
approximating a cost benefit analysis
and that has it's that's tough too
because it's not that easy to assign
costs and benefits in a quantitative
manner
having said all that it's well it's an
amazing study
not only because of what it reveals
which is a 0.2 decline in overall
mortality but also in that the
the researchers felt so strongly about
their
findings that they
came right out and said that this was
ineffective policy and that isn't that
common um for researchers who generally
hold off on drawing that sorts of
conclusions they they kind of lay out
the fact that black and white they're
typically not going to come out as black
and white as what you're saying yes yes
exactly exactly and so
so that's that's really something we
rushed to imitate a totalitarian state
in panic and the consequence of that
according to this study was
there's zero there's nothing positive
about it now i've talked with some
democrats about this study because they
were paying attention to it and their
response is
something like
well
it did help control hospital overrun
and
time will tell whether or not that's
true i think the data suggesting that
covid vaccines decreased the seriousness
of illness when people contracted covid
who were vaccinated i think that data is
credible
i could be wrong about that because
things are being done in a rush and it's
very difficult to draw appropriate
scientific conclusions in a rush but i
think the bulk of the information
suggests that but i also think that is
not how they were marketed and that was
not the initial intent to merely reduce
severity of the illness it was to reduce
transmission and and so forth and and
then of course this is a cost-benefit
analysis which says yeah there was some
gain on that front conceivably maybe
although all-cause mortality doesn't
seem to have gone down much at all but
the economic
the secondary consequences were
devastating and well we don't even know
what the secondary consequences are yet
you know the collu here's one secondary
consequence
which is revealed in what you just read
the collusion of the press and the
government
like how do you know that's not worse
than the epidemic it could easily be
worse than the epidemic or the idea that
now we've been
coerced
into
having to share our medical information
with people all through the bureaucratic
hierarchy all the way down to servers
and restaurants so we've trained people
that that's okay to ask
and also to offer
is that worse than the pandemic
well
these are
arguably
all of this involves violation of our
fundamental rights
where's the evidence that that's not
worse well we're going to see it play
out well the collusion between the press
and the government
that's so intense in canada as already
said when the premier of ex-premier of
newfoundland wanted to launch his
constitutional challenge
he couldn't use a mainstream news source
that's a bloody catastrophe much as i
dislike cbc which is a lot by the way
i think that it's an absolute
catastrophe that it's come to that and
that's just one of
you know two consequences of the
lockdown there's the supply chain
problem that's a big one you know
my publisher penguin told me a week and
a half ago we're talking about putting
out a two volume
set of my last two books which i would
really like to do they're going to do
that in great britain
i i think that people would
turn to it as a gift for graduations and
so on that would be a nice set for that
they told me they can't get paper
this is penguin random house right and
it's paper
paper isn't that complex given how
complex everything is the fact that
there are paper shortages that's a big
deal i was in a mazda dealership in
canada a couple of a couple of months
ago now
they had one car
one isn't very many cars
you know and and so we have no idea what
the supply line crunch is going to
produce in terms of economic
seriously and then the next issue is
well how about all the money we've been
printing
you know we've already seen that produce
a massive
bubble expansion in housing prices
that's being driven by other factors
how do we know that's not worse than the
pandemic
you know it could easily be i'm not
saying that it is because i don't know
but that's the issue i don't know and
this is partly why this mad rush to
impose top-down
solutions to complex problems this is in
some sense what makes me a conservative
insofar as i am
it's part of the caution i learned as a
social scientist so if you enjoyed this
little short segment from the podcast
that we did here's another short segment
to watch or if you want to see the
entire podcast click over here take care
everybody bye-bye
[Music]
you